public will have a chance to pay
respects to the Reverend Billy Graham
before he is buried next Friday his body
will lie in repose on Monday and Tuesday
at his library in Charlotte North
Carolina the famed evangelist influence
transcended not just religion but also
politics he met with and spiritually
advised every president from Harry
Truman to Barack Obama while his council
was bipartisan his evangelical movement
became a political force courted by
Republican candidates Russell Moore is
president of the ethics and religious
liberty Commission of the Southern
Baptist Convention good morning Russell
thanks morning being here Billy Graham's
influence on Christian life in America
how big was it I think it was massive
and partly because of his uniqueness as
a communicator innovating with
technologies but part of it is because
of how how the same he was as the rest
of the Christian message he never he
never cut corners on the gospel he was
never embarrassed about the message that
people can find forgiveness through the
shed blood of Jesus Christ and that was
the message that he gave over and over
again so that the person who's
drug-addicted in the homeless shelter
and the United States Senator or the
billionaire find the same message coming
from Billy Graham of the grace of God
through the good news of Jesus Christ so
interesting to think of him in those
historic historical terms because you've
called him the most significant
Christian evangelist since the Apostle
Paul right I mean that's high praise
Jesus come back so that's right well I
did I think part of that is because of
the time in which he emerged so he was
able to use technologies that simply
weren't available at any other time in
history by using radio yes very similar
to in the New Testament times the use of
Roman roads and and things that that
hadn't existed before he used radio he
used television and later years even the
internet and he was always a step ahead
of everyone else but always getting back
to that that old-time message of what
the good news of Christ is could it be
that Billy Graham had an iPhone that
would be nice to know I would not be
surprised you know you he once said that
one of his big regrets if he had to talk
about regrets in life was that he
crossed the line into politics he was so
revered and admired on both sides of the
aisle why do you think he regretted that
well because he looked back at the tapes
water Watergate his close association
with Richard Nixon which I think was
more personal than it was political but
I think later he looked back and so how
those those lines can become blurred and
people can easily confuse a partisan
political agenda for the kingdom of God
that of course transcends all of that
and so Billy Graham's primary goal was
to reach people all people with the
message of God's love of the Day of
Judgment that's coming for all people
and of the freedom that comes through
forgiveness through through the cross
and so he he I think more than made up
for whatever errors he might have made
in his past Christ's message is love thy
neighbor don't judge don't be prideful
when you listen to political talk today
whether it's by our officials or online
you know that is does not exist does
that argue for a Graham like figure to
jump into politics to lift it up or to
stay way away because none of Christ's
message can be found in it well we need
people in politics who of course are
have consciences that are guided by by
morality and by the Spirit of God but I
think we also need people are standing
outside of politics speaking a word of
grace and the redemption and of coming
judgment and I think that's what Graham
was able to do he was able to say well
we all know where we're sinners we know
that no matter how much we try to say
everything's relative and everything's
fine we know that's not true in our own
hearts at the same time he loved people
so Billy Graham was never angry Billy
Graham was never resentful he was never
warring against the culture in the world
around and he was John 3:16 he being
loved the world because God loved the
world enough to say come to Christ I saw
the time I saw an old interview that
Diane Sawyer had done with him years ago
and he said when the time came he
doesn't want people to say nice things
about him because he said he didn't
deserve it what he wants hear from the
Lord is well done well done my servant
you know him personally what stands out
to you about him what stood out to me
was the gravity first time I met him I
was in my early twenties very young in
ministry and walking into the room it
was almost like coming into the room
with an Old Testament prophet in one
sense but at the same time there was
this warmth
and so I think of him sort of like I
heard someone mention a preacher in
London many years ago and said he was a
steamroller but a gentle steamroller and
I think that was true of Billy Graham he
had a gentleness and a warmth but the
gravity of the message was was
overwhelming and still endurance we need
that message these days too he has had a
profound impact and over the past
century thank you thank you very much
Rusty Moore hey Russell Moore thank you